plus de 320 filières organisées de
clandestins ont été démantelés en France
l'année dernière c'est un chiffre inédit
la France est transpercé de tous côtés
par des filières d'aide à l'entrée des
clandestins en un an 69 réseaux
internationaux acheminant des migrants
illégaux ont été neutralisés selon nos
informations de nombreuses sans papiers
afghan débarquent en France depuis
l'Autriche et la Suisse via la ligne de
train balmulhouse une fois sur le
territoire les plus jeunes sont prises
en charge par l'aide sociale à l'enfance
pour un coût annuel moyen estimé à 50
000 euros par personne on les appelle
les MNA les mineurs non accompagnés
tristement sur représentés dans les
statistiques d'auteurs de cambriolage ou
de vols à l'arraché si les flux de
clandestins venant de Biélorussie se
sont taris depuis la guerre en Ukraine
les trafiquants ont modifié les circuits
les policiers ont démantelé 47 filières
dites d'aide au transit l'année dernière
donnant lieu à 167 interpellations de
trafiquants dans cette catégorie bien
particulière le transport de migrants
par small boat depuis les côtes
françaises vers la Grande-Bretagne est
un sujet de préoccupation majeur près de
46 000 clandestins originaires d'une
cinquantaine de pays ont rejoint
l'Eldorado britannique par la mer en
2022 contre 30000 l'année précédente
désormais les forces de sécurité qui
déploient certaines nuits jusqu'à 800
hommes sur le littoral français ont
intercepté près de 60% des quelques 2000
traversées répertoriés en un an 170
filières d'aides au maintien
c'est-à-dire qui fixent les clandestins
sur le territoire national ont également
été démantelés l'année dernière au total
477 malfaiteurs présumés ont été placés
en garde à vue alors qu'ils étaient des
migrants à s'établir clandestinement en
France pour épauler les policiers et les
gendarmes sur le terrain un groupe de
veille cyber est appelé avoir le jour
objectif intercepter des recruteurs qui
font miroiter aux candidats à l'exil
notamment via des réseaux comme Tik Tok
des traversées ensoleillées en canaux
vers l'Espagne et l'Angleterre derrière
ce mirage ce sont des milliers de vie de
naufragés qui finissent en l'outil dans
les cimetières marins de la Manche et de
la Méditerranée en 2021 45 personnes ont
trouvé la mort dans la Manche et 3231
dans les eaux méditerranéennes
[Musique]